cryptome
riesigen
950 millionen hier die meisten
fasziniert von dem was geschafft hätten
dann kriege ich mehr profit wenn meine
follower mehr profit machen
kannst du und hielt damit darum gar
ich dafür waren ein monat in zwei
fabriken
investieren musik franken und finde
unser was macht das mit um ihm
investment ich werde das jetzt fitter zu
werden war schon ziemlich schon jetzt
class
400 stützen so gesetzt dass
vor ihm selbst experiment hat fankreis
für mich etwas verrückter weiter was wir
da machen die sich franke vom eigenen
geld online börse zahlen und kryptischer
muss jetzt das war einfach tönt einmal
am anfang nicht überfordert es gibt
nicht nur viele tormann die krypta
wahlgang schaffe sondern die wichtige
frage ist weil die war ich überhaupt
nicht es geht auch mal über sagt
und ding ist jetzt der wiener und
unbekannte so eine ist desto größter
schafft möglichkeit für den größten
anstieg aber desto größer ist das risiko
dass sie die andere richtig geld
verdient um ins risiko darum möglichst
bald mal die mir auf die größte crypto
börse und trafen die bekannt ist die
wahrlich bitcoin und jetzt auch
offiziell
0022 bitcoin damit ich mein grundstock
an für mehr muss ich aber erst mal was
ich investiere so hollywood hills im
internet und liefert neues phänomen
mit einem tor in front die videos sind
mega sensation musik gemacht eine was
seine gefühle vor scheiße ich verpasse
bis am besten ist
lautet jeder tag also videos mit
sadistischen titel über die unmittelbare
machbar weckrufe egal ob befindet
irisches club kräftig tvo in dubai haupt
und forschte millionen lied über den
kanal erreicht findet gebracht gründe
sehr cool hat das geklappt vielen dank
ja danke dass ich hier dabei sein kann
ich mich im moment ihren recherchen
wunder was stelle am besten musik frank
war mein ziel ist ja dass ich mich
möglichst
frühpensionieren lassen kann und einen
lamborghini kaufen kann was redest du
mir chris also für den für den zu den
profis der dokumentation wenn du jetzt
echt was spannendes machen möchtest klar
dann kannst du jetzt nicht 4000 franken
kaufen und dann geht man hoch 4 prozent
an 8000 irrt sich angemacht ist jetzt
nicht so spannend werden meiner meinung
nach immer noch das beste denn du kannst
die drei wochen kannst du eben
hochrechnen 4 prozent in drei wochen ist
wahnsinn es schien einfach etwas mehr
freizeit bekommst keine grauen haare ich
würde sagen langfristig gesehen bekannt
kaufen einfach gar nichts machen ist das
beste würde jetzt vielleicht auch nur
drei wochen frist ein bisschen
langweilig aussehen aber die besten
wenn langfristig investiert das beste
ich frage mich wieso er unter seine
videos sohn links postet es wird mit
einem bonus bei der krypto börse wenn
die data mit karte zahle unterfangen
trader was sie hat klasse ist es nun
ford im trading geld verliert
das haben wir so ein bisschen dann auch
irritiert bei deinem videos dass du am
schluss immer so
teil hasst
moduliert links ein baust wie siehst du
das dann mit deiner verantwortung weil
sowohl du ja noch mehr leute an ich ins
trading wenn ich trader und leute traden
über meine lieblings wo ich dann eben
auch profite bekommen weil die börse
traffic bekommen wegen mir dann krieg
ich mehr profit wenn meine follower mehr
profit machen das heißt unser anreiz
geht in die gleiche richtung je mehr
meine community profitiert desto mehr
mache ich profit wenn ich meine
community ins versagen stürze bewusst
und die würden liquidiert werden das
heißt das geld das die einzahlen würden
sie verlieren dann ist das geld weg
dieses geld geht an die börse aber ja
große verantwortung
am ende des tages denke ich einfach
versucht richtig konnten so
rüberzubringen dass ich im großen und
ganzen deutlich mehr mehrwert stiften
als vielleicht ein paar leute meine
message verstehen und daraus eine
breitseite bekommen vom markt mit dem
mehrwert meint er sie nie weniger zum
finanzsystem wie zum beispiel will die
zentralbank auf der welt so viel geld
drucken und sich so die inflation der
wahl ist und ganz stetig vermindere
zurufen bitcoin umstieg weil dir sind
für eine 20 millionen festgesetzt dass
sie die beste und ganz sicher führt weit
stabilisiert ich somit kommt es wirklich
eine sehr coole sache wo ich denke das
ist der mittelfinger gegenüber der
traditionellen bankenwelt der
traditionelle finanz leitung des
geldsystems und meiner meinung nach die
beste möglichkeit über die lange frist
nicht faszinierten von sechs monate
passiert aber einfach mal über den
nächsten paar jahre seine kaufkraft zu
sichern
vielen dank ihr
die kritische haltung gegenüber vom
finanzsystem ist der grund wieso bitcoin
2008 als es die digitale alternative
kreiert wurde mich die krypta in
pflanzen sind sozusagen die politischen
vertreter von einer idee huttwil mache
das aber nicht denn dass sie
schlussendlich mit ihren videos wenn
geld verdienen ist klar
auf die kurze frist bringen mich
investment die pikon nicht wirklich viel
grün drum entscheide mit kaka rat vom
quiz trader und bringen mit basics b
wenn ich so trennt musste ran lassen
kann ich dann vielleicht im voraus sagen
ob der kurs wird stieger oder caillats
für die tri trading-tipps dritte diverse
telegramm gruppe b und der fahrer gott
direkt wenn um cryptome bis passiert
aber ich merke wie sieht für das luft
und morgen ist meistens erste woche der
kurs checker und marbeck sports letzte
bild das ganze einfach 24 7 läuft ist
auch so schnell aber es kann sie das
irgendwo zum ist in der nacht ein kurs
um 5 cent
obergeschoss am nächsten tag scheiße
sage ich dass verpasst also es entsteht
so und trug zum konstant eben wir den
kurs als checker und konstanz ich
versuche jetzt informieren valley war
ich war jetzt nur erwartet
könnt irgendwie 200 fachanwalt können
den rückstand und den beschluss auf der
suche nach dem warum wurde es könnte
machen anders als der normale aktien 24
mit crypt australian es so bin ich froh
dass nach kohls analysieren und nach
einem schatz am 12 nach mexiko findet
ein sonnenschutz und mache erstmal kein
grund zum viele haben es die profitable
trade gemacht 7 franken quinn aber das
schießt micha und wieso
schließlich gesellte please steht jetzt
nur wieder rufe ich merke hat nur
gewinne machen und dabei wie gierig bist
du einfach machen wie scheiß trade und
jetzt seid ihr immer hätte ich da tun
dass du nicht mehr immer schon
hundertmal mehr dann hat schon
hundertmal mehr gewinn gemacht
doch gewisse es muss noch mehr drin liga
aus dem sie befragen rückkanal klasse
dass man mit dem hebel trading das ist
ein risiko oder die art vom trading no
megatrucks also als der antrag gemacht
darauf setzte dass der kurs nun
weitergeht und da ist gar
mit super dollar investiert damit einmal
apple das auf mich und trader
-
am nächsten tag bin ich ein grad wie man
schränkt liquidiert wird und thomas sms
quiz abstieg ist zum glück für mich aber
dass ich nur so wenig investiert haben
und man muss sich das mal vorstellen mit
500 fragen gemacht denn ist der kurs
zwar nur ein paar prozent kate aber
schlussendlich mit dem großen apple hat
dort wird der ganze trade liquidiert und
verliert alles und genau so verliert
liegt aber
glatt erfahre
ich was kann ich nicht er eine schiene
begann zum das verstarb walter und
suchen in ehemalige physiklehrer der us
teenager zum ein experte in sachen
klub-boss wurde und geht an workshops
drüber ich wollte vor allem wissen wir
haben virtuelles nicht existierendes
geld überhaupt so ein hype wie mir und
auch viele andere auslöser
lukaszewitz vorstelle wie so ein
wasserbett stell dir vor die klasse
clown würdest du dir schreibe einfach so
ist blödsinn
rafi pitts aus und schrieb so 5 sowie
zwei notches diene und jetzt kommt es ja
wirklich sie dass irgendein anderer
douglas oder auf der seite springt
und der
gp2 und die alle wurden klasse 10 können
jetzt leistet immer von 5 kg zwei
einander als alte und der neue head 2
und es ist ja wirklich möglich oder das
andere auf der blödsinn aufspringen und
findet ja wahnsinn pixo sich weiter und
entwickelt sich so nach dynamik und alle
wenn plötzlich pizza und dass er weiter
spenden oder man könnte sagen danke ja
gut jetzt fragt pflichten dritten seit
jahren also ich würde pizza sozusagen
die ersten zwei jahre
heinz peter franz josef gaben
abgeschrieben oder so
wie bigpoint oder damit deine pizza im
chat dinge für schulsachen und sich
natürlich nie in den anderen normaler
laden und dem team der gruppe chat ist
veranschaulichung vor der blog zeigt der
ort wo crypto weniger verschickt werden
die nachricht täte ich eigentlich ein
blog vor transaktion beinhaltet und
jeder dem kettcar 6 wer wieviel hätte
dann könnte ich aber einfach immer
wieder klasse chat und zu sagen hey
jungs von
coach ist ja genau das sei das problem
oder wir jetzt dass ich genau das spiel
für die wii
spiele frau
und dazu das verhindere das war immer so
dass mathematische problem nicht das
nennt man genau das mining aus dem pc
zeigt mir denn der ur sowie hans banal
die art wie bitcoin eigentlich so happ
stellt und davon bereits mache dass ich
eigentlich meinen oder was auch immer
sehr primitiv erleben mit der tastatur
dass ich eigentlich mal einige besucher
den hash nennt man das und aus der stadt
herrscht wie sogar den hedge womöglich
fehlenden julia ford center austria ist
gefunden mit dem wir sind immer noch da
natürlich es kein eis punkte das
kommende jahr aber es ist zu wenig oder
viel klasse chat für spitzenwerte bis
zum 30 das meine ich aber mega aufwändig
es braucht entsprechend hardware
spezielle computer und so viel strom
dass es extrem tür wird sein dort pizza
bach bezirks ist bitcoins meiner und für
die meisten nicht in frage
da ich bereit die der klassische
teenager los ich hoffe ich so bissig
gibt 0 2 aber nur wenn du mir auf reale
bank war aber zum beispiel 15 30 und das
so das ist einfach der wind macht mit
dem gewinn macht also cash ich so oder
so forsch zu real und geld aufschluss
zeichen und können natürlich mit dem
koffer und übergab es ging mit der
wieder ganz viel neuware wo der hype und
dynamik vom fanklub tv event
reproduzieren es gibt sogar so fit
gemacht wurde ist zum club der wahl
ihrer hörner und die er jetzt an
marktkapitalisierung von 7 entries
gehalt milliarde franken so jetzt also
doch kein wonach man nun gemacht worden
ist mehr marktkapitalisierung
swatch und credit suisse zusammen also
das nicht absurd es geht aber nun 100
andere accounts von absurder sind wie
zum beispiel de landsberg die hängt
crowley funktion als alex w 's sondern
es geht nur darum ein hype-thema
auslöser so dass der preis möglichst
höher steigt und die alu davon trinkt
sie sind denn ganz für geld machen
sobald dir dein erstes user mit krachten
zusammen das ganze einander prompt
ändern der gold rush ist ab juli will
die weste ohne jegliche regulierung weil
ich so arg fix bin natürlich auf das
woche noch sorgte monique ganz früher an
investieren es ist halb eins in der
nacht und ich bin mehr oder weniger der
ganz so wie jetzt war ja am 6 das
potenzial hat dass die unis vielfach
erwartet stehen und hat tatsächlich
etwas gefunden das ganze projekt war sie
wird in der studie heißt clip dazu und
diese absurdität und risiko halbiert
es geht um das game ökosystem auf der
blog zeigt kann man verschiedene
diktieren schafe jeder mit anderen
kröten die sind den verschiedenen seiten
und doch damit es so erwarb für das muss
man aber zuerst aber verstanden virtuell
ich hoffe wurde nach zufall schlüpfen
und eines tier gefunden also nfc
ökosystem wie es heißt sie momentan der
ort wo liegt am allermeisten geld machen
die
rohstoffversorgung
400 franken bald wird es aber nur zart
muss ich den vorgang so ist wird die
ermittlung jetzt aber
ich könnte es wirklich hatte
am morgen
den launch von dem projekt nicht weiter
dies forderte wiegt 400 franken
investiert als ein anderer kann dieser
transfer von amerika nach update müsse
das quasi schafe und es ist irgendwas
mit drin stecken blieben und ich weiß
nicht was passiert ist
ich kann ziemlich sicher jetzt gerade
400 sturz in sand gesetzt
und ich glaube ich
habe so hart für die red bull kann ich
der typ der den kauf und was passiert
jetzt
ich weiß nicht was passiert ist ich weiß
nicht mehr was passiert ist das ist das
problem ich habe immer sagen was problem
ist nicht dass gekauft hat das hätten
unzählige chat mit sache 20.00
uhr ab weil
dieses budget [ __ ] you
54 das hier ja morgen mini nächtliche
eskapade
findet es an die
spendensammler punkt 8 nach zweieinhalb
wochen
wo ich mich an schafft frage was mache
ich da ich genau will aufwand und ertrag
stadt ich kein verhalten ist praktisch
doppelt
eu-vertrag ich - wenn es gut und nur und
jetzt ganz gut und für schlägt plus und
aus dem grund habe ich mich jetzt
entscheidet sich für tätig vom trader
zurückziehe einer sitzung mit finanziell
schützen das risiko investieren
besonders
aber andererseits viel wichtiger zum
psychischen schütze nicht mal mehr ganz
nach zweieinhalb wochen also ich frage
mich wie gott seine lüth wo mit dem ihr
es galt für die info show jahre baby
sind was sind das für lüthis trade
center das war ein yusuf s aber so eine
chance im irak die schweiz geflüchtet
mit 11 bitcoin und jetzt mit 21
multi millionär wäre das büro gerade die
möglich vom paradeplatz
dort wann ist die vermutlich jüngste
selfmade multimillionär von land und
hätte das gesamte vermögen mit klub-boss
gemacht aber wie auf wunsch das elf
jahre getroffen ich hab jetzt bitcoin
also weiß ich komme ursprünglich aus dem
kurdischen nordirak mit drei jahre hat
flüchtet schweizer familie zusammen und
ihre familienchronik
worden und mit ihr schließt sie oft erst
ziemlich ordnung sie nach einer
abmahnung mit delphi hat meine
großmutter denn gut ist dann eine
mitbewohnerin operation oder so geld
muss ja mit bevor ich das finde ich
nicht möglich sie ihre geld schicke und
dennoch lehre von complementa lässig
sucht und so als elfjährige kniffliger
google besseres geld und so scheiße
bauen kann und sozial gerecht und
ja da kann man nicht von bitcoins um sie
mit großmutter schicken die
operationszahlen wo es geht ja so
schnell
die ganze spielsachen genau es
ausverkauft die nächsten kanton bern und
als gelben vorträgen erster bitcoins
kaufte und die preise des konstanzer 15
und ein bitcoin über 40 franken wert der
dort waren hätten immer mehr bitcoins
kraft auffangen trader mit sunny und mit
16 17 millionen
probiert mit ganz bitcoins tag auf einig
mit einer rose zu hoffen
das
problem
bewusst dass wasser sagt seine eigene
jeder tag genau vor pc und durch strafen
also nichts bis 17 18 emmanuel trader
nach scharfer analytiker musste 71
merkwürdig das fußballspiel uns und das
schafft viel zu bruch das ist inzwischen
so groß dass ich nicht das hobby und so
hätte das als so junger yaris kalte also
was jetzt mit irgendetwas psyche mit 17
jahren gemerkt wenn ich das jetzt noch
weiterziehen will die wahrscheinlich
verrückt also brauchen eigentlich sie
haben
ich verabschiede mich von dort waren
weil er muss wie der avant nix und bio
besichtigung aber nicht an der normale
[Musik]
ganz spontan somit auch die besichtigung
und ich bin gespannt wie das wird
leider animateur für filme aber was ich
nach der besichtigung konzack es ist
schön straße ohne jemals im lake city 25
zum ende dieser garten und direkte blick
über ziel ist wunderschön aber einfach
absurd dass ich das in eine 20 jährige
bett und frank horn leiste nur durch
kryptisch
wenn ich schlafe
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der junge der nicht
was das problem ist
eigentlich
egal ob im schnyder sich
selbstbewusst aber auch zwischen junge
typisch und nach
nach der besichtigung wenn man nur alle
zwei meter gasse das schloss das halt
immer nur im nah und ich kann mir damit
verstieß sorgt ist überhaupt möglich sie
das danke dann auch und mir sind bisher
erfolgreichste trades zeigt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und
150 millionen
es ist einfach nur crazy
investmentfonds 600 franken
159 millionen machen und das sind aber
das sind so die erfolgsgeschichte aber
noch viele leute das wiederholt es im
fall von dort war er auf das geld also
ich habe das niemals kerscher das
handelsvolumen vor dem köln oder
investiert hat ist das heißt es bleibt
einfach so virtuelles spielgeld damals
im sprach mit dem ur spanischen frage ob
das ganze mit der krücke weil ich
überhaupt zukunft hat oder einfach nur
groß die blase ist wo irgendwann
zerplatzt
moment wenn du mir mit trinkt zum
beispiel digital-zeit stubbe wie sich
der himmel bank nur als dritte dann aber
wo sich gestellt ob sie die ihrem konto
zu schutzmaßnahmen und mir aufs konto 10
stuttgart
und wenn wir das in der maz ab
nachrichten verlauf der verlauf von
jeder hätten auch noch 7 handy die
wirtschaft hatte dass sie das aber
nachlassen wir brauchen tritt jede mit
ihm darum glaube ich habe das
längerfristige sich das virtuelle gegen
die menschheit bis keine mühen die sätze
wie schafft der fall dass irgendein werk
maschine wird dass ihre zukunft vor
krypta war für mich wirklich spannend im
moment aber er liebe es einfach also
unberechenbar die welt wo es land
bitcoins offizielle wahl geführt und
richtiges anders klub der welt ganz
verbietet und einiges so volatil ist das
ein tweet feuerleiter kurs um 20 prozent
beeinflusst im monat zurück zu ärgern -
etwa für cody an bord hat und was ich
sage also ich hab ich will der wieder
vom absurden monat voller virtuelle
pizzas und
die sind übrigens wieder ruft 8 also die
hab ich wieder was ich plane mit der
statthalter und des barock oder macht
einfach weiter jetzt macht die woche
handy schon massiv höheren werten bei
einfacher wieder verkauft was mit
investment betrifft gesetzliche
schlachtruf bin ich 15 prozent die -
herrscht nachmaligen mit sand oder sie
aber es ist einfach auch sind so wenige
bürger transaktions und trading gebühren
weg gegangen dass ich einfach den
überblick verloren ganz ehrlich
weil das trader braucht auch so viel
zeit und energie also ich das würde ich
sicher also das würde ich sicher mehr
machen was man darüber lecker vielleicht
machen ist pro monat eine krypta weniger
langfristig zu investieren
und jetzt natürlich wunder wärest du mit
glück da war ich auch schon mit bitten
oder löschen die betriebe davon für mehr
so reportage von rec abonnieren doch da
auf youtube
[Musik]